My name is athanasia aasu I am the
coordinator of the Smart materials group
of The Italian Institute of Technology
in Genova We Are working on new plastic
materials this Kind of bioplastics are
coming from the Waste of edible
vegetables so the part of the vegetable
that in Any  case we would Throw away We
have tried Different Kind of vegetables
like parsley
spinut cacao Rice we Take the
and
process Acid organic Acid We dilute all
the was of the vegetables this Powder in
Powder form after few Hours or few Days
depending on the veget We Get  this
solution homogeneous Solutions we it in
a
mold The solvent is evaporated take
plastic Take the wax of the veget and we
Turn It into material can use plastic so
The Waste is not Waste anymore The Waste
Becomes a useful material We Are
targeting specific applications taking
Advantage  of the properties of the plant
itself for example we want to pass the
antioxidant properties of the spinach To
The Plastic that is based on the spin
the smell ising To The Plastic because
are Keep
SP